let's go next to our caller from the
three four seven area code who's calling
today from three four seven
hi David this is Katie for cone from
Florida as well hey how are you can you
hear me
yes I can I heard you I I had a question
I guess it's not really a question today
I just want were kinda given my opinion
also I do apologize if we must bring
this up again because you had discussion
with this just on the previous caller
coming with the previous previous caller
about Bernie Sanders and this was born
this current debacle that they're
involved in so in my opinion I feel like
Warren if you're an honest and decent
human being I think you should just come
out and just you know put her on paper
and just tell the you know the people
hey listen he said this he said this in
this particular context and the fact
that the warrant the fact that Warren
isn't doing this is a kind of
disappointment to me and I know I was a
big Warren supporter as well you know
Bernie's obviously is my number one
choice I'm very progressive but you know
Warren probably number two I will still
go over her but I feel that it's it's
really disappointing that she's not
really coming out and really just
clarifying that the context of what
Bernie said yeah there has to be more
context like we we you know Elizabeth
Warren is is a 70 year old woman who's
speaking style and thinking style we are
familiar with Bernie Sanders is a I
think he's 77 or 78 he's a 77 78 year
old intelligent man with decades of
public speaking and and thinking
extemporaneously on the record the idea
that he would cryptically say I don't
believe a woman can win and there's no
other context and there's no
understanding of what he's really saying
by that is is laughable there's just no
way that the conversation is that simple
and that's where I get to Elizabeth
Warren when she has confirmed that he
said it she has notably said nothing
else and it would be irresponsible not
to say
he said I don't think a woman can win
and what I understood that to mean was
he doesn't think women can be president
right if that's because that's what's
being implied but there's no way in hell
that that's what Bernie said and
therefore absolutely shouldn't be
clarified Bernie said I think given the
political environment and Trump being
president and sexism that a woman
wouldn't win in 2020 I'm not saying he
said that but the point is there there
is obviously some additional context
that would immediately dissolve this
controversy which Elizabeth Warren has
not put forward and I believe that she
should yeah it's disappointing you know
and the other things that you know
they're both progressives I get it
they're both running for the same
Democratic nomination but you know the
ultimate goal is there they're actually
good friends and they share a lot of
common policies yes and you know she
just should should come out in support I
mean not support him but just you know
clear the record and it's this point
that she's not doing it if let me just
say one more thing if she truly believes
that what Bernie said was just a sexist
attack on the idea of women presidents
she should say that the fact that she
hasn't and is allowing it to be implied
inferred by some people is is a very
wrong way to go yes absolutely I
completely agree I'd well we'll see what
happens maybe I'm speaking too soon
maybe she will come up with the
statement but as of right now you know
it is a little bit just disappointing to
me because I was a you know huge worm
fan I like the previous caller said I
was too poor for her but it is uh you
know disappointed anyways thanks for
taking my call I'm a big fan - oh thank
you and people work all right thanks so
much great to hear from you that does it
for calls today I apologize I was not
able to get to everyone I never am but I
do the best I can we will take calls
again and I look forward to hearing from
many more of you next time